hey guys it's Jan here wasn't it tough
spotting the Easter eggs for the good
dinosaur at the cinema but with the
movie out on DVD I've been able to find
eight Pixar and Disney Easter eggs and
references you probably miss when you
first saw the movie if you noticed any
others I'd love to hear about them in
the comments below and of course as this
is an easter egg video there will be
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the
movie so if you're not ready for that
check out my non-spoiler review of the
movie right here let's kick off with a
big Pixar regular a113 was quite a hard
one to find but you can spot it on the
fence when Arlo goes to feed the
chickens
the a113 Easter Egg has appeared in
every single Pixar movie to date and is
an homage to the classroom at California
Institute of the Arts where animation
greats such as John Lasseter and Brad
Bird studied Hank from Pixar's upcoming
movie finding dory appears in the rock
pool that Arlo falls into after being
bitten by a gopher you'll need to watch
it very carefully as when Arlo first
balls in the octopuses eyes are closed
by the way in finding Dory Hank will be
voiced by Modern Family star ed O'Neil
there's a clever nod to monster
University character squishy during the
hilarious hallucination that Arlo and
spot have after they eat some rotten
fruit Arlo and spot float through the
air swap heads and the five eyes which
appear on Arlo are a reference to Scott
squishy Squibbles he was actually voiced
by the good dinosaur directed Peter Sohn
and you'll need eagle eyes to spot this
one but during that same hallucination
seen the luxo ball actually floats by
the luxo ball originates from Pixar's
very first animation a short film called
luxo jr. which features both the luxo
ball and the two desk lamps one of which
appears in Pixar's logo by the way the
hallucination scene also has shades of
when Dumbo and Timothy Q Mouse got drunk
on champagne and started hallucinating
pink and multicolored elephants and spot
might be an ancestor of Finding Nemo
Starla they both have a very similar
shaped face and eyes freckles and a snub
nose in Finding Nemo Darla is called a
fish killer and interestingly the first
name that forrest woodbush the pet
collector comes up with the spot is
killer
and in that naming seen when forrest
woodbush and our luo compete to see who
gets to keep spot through a whole bunch
of shoutouts to other Pixar characters
the squirt the playful turtle from
Finding Nemo Frank the combine harvester
from cars
stinky which could have been chosen for
stinky Pete the prospector from Toy
Story to violet the daughter of Bob and
Helen Parr and The Incredibles and spike
which is the alter-ego for the slug like
employee Augustus Jones at monsters Inc
oh and by the way spike was also the
real name of the dog who played Old
Yeller in the classic 1957 Disney movie
which director Peter Sohn has said was a
big influence on the good dinosaur when
all Owens spotted running away from a
bunch of pterodactyls they see what
looks like the silhouette of an adult
Apatosaurus in the distance and Easter
Egg for the Dinoco sign in Toy Story
although as they get closer they see the
silhouette is actually made up of two
tier X's and finally this one was
perhaps the toughest to spot but
floating out here at the very start of
the film and the asteroid belt is a
Pizza Planet truck itself the Pizza
Planet truck first appeared in Toy Story
and has made an appearance in every
Pixar film since then except the
Incredibles so guys which are the easter
eggs did you spot in the good dinosaur
and tell me which is your favorite Pixar
movie if you enjoyed this video I'll
have another Easter Egg video coming
along shortly for Disney Zootopia and
you might also like to check out these
25 awesome behind-the-scenes facts about
the making of Pixar's inside out as
always your like comments and shares are
hugely appreciated and do please
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers